[Musique]
les réserves pétrolières s'amenuisent
lentement mais sûrement ingénieurs et
scientifiques réfléchissent à d'autres
moyens d'alimenter nos villes en énergie
les solutions sont inventives
le soleil la fusion nucléaire le vent et
la vapeur sous nos pieds se met une
source d'énergie encore peu exploité
propre accessible et très abondantes
le plus difficile est d'aller chercher
cette énergie c'est un travail dur il
faut supporter des conditions pénibles
et parfois dangereuse ça dépasse un
certain niveau vous perdez connaissance
et s'il n'y a personne pour vous sortir
de là c'est la mort assurée en islande
comme ailleurs des hommes acceptent ces
risques pour que cette énergie
renouvelable devienne une énergie
d'avenir
la géothermie se propose de puiser
l'intense chaleur présente au centre de
la terre
la géothermie dit horizontale à usage
domestique prend cette énergie à environ
un mètre sous la surface
un fluide circule en circuit fermé entre
le sous sol du terrain où ils se
réchauffent et la maison où il restitue
son pouvoir chauffant seul inconvénient
la surface nécessaire pour le captage
représente le double de la surface à
chauffer le principe est adapté aux
maisons individuelles mais inapplicable
en milieu urbain toutefois il est
possible de produire de l'énergie à
grande échelle pour les villes et les
industries cela se fait déjà
[Musique]
l'islande est un pays spécialisé dans la
géothermie industriel 70% de son énergie
renouvelable et nos bonnes ventes en
grande partie grâce à la géothermie
[Musique]
en islande cette île de neige et de
glace située dans l'atlantique nord et
géothermie a connu une véritable
explosion dès les années 1980
ici on pratique la géothermie haute
énergie on capte sous terre de la vapeur
que l'on convertira en électricité
ouverte il ya deux ans la centrale daily
show qui doit déjà s'agrandir pour
doubler sa capacité de production avec
les soucis quotidiens de tous les
chantiers on n'aura pas la grille
aujourd'hui tout est à l'échelle des
énormes flux de vapeur à traiter les
pièces détachées les engins les outils
vas-y faire c'est facile un chat dort
c'est mon outil préféré quant à ces
dizaines de kilomètres de tuyaux et de
vannes à contrôler
ce sont autant de problèmes à résoudre
pour les ingénieurs quand les premières
pompes fonctionnaires on avait un
maximum de pression
pour ces travaux d'extension les équipes
sont fortement tributaires des
conditions météo parfois exécrables en
islande la glace s'accroche à la
structure et la casse et l'enlever
exercerait trop de pression il faut la
laisser
il s'est profilée c'est le bon prix les
attendus pour doubler la production il
faut deux fois plus de vapeur
il appartient aux géologues de la
trouver il faut fournir assez d'énergie
pour le projet dans son ensemble
on essaie d'extraire à cette vapeur pour
les nouvelles turbines à 3000 kilomètres
de là en france on a une approche
différente de la géothermie
[Musique]
ici il n'ya pas de vapeur naturel pour
en créer il faut injecter de l'eau dans
les roches chaudes à 5000 mètres de
profondeur dans ce village d'alsace
un projet pilote est en cours un
ambitieux pari technologique
le moteur tourne tout est prêt
ce parti est un pari ne va pas sans
imprévu
moi j'ai de la flotte qui coule j'en ai
même plus qu'avant
de sérieux problèmes techniques pour la
faire échouer le projet
aux commandes
je leur ai dit
haili shahidi en islande
markus frei se félicite d'être impliqué
dans un projet écologique c'est bon pour
la planète et c'est bien de faire son
possible
c'est une énergie propre
la géothermie est loin d'être une
science exacte le géologue gretar et
personne ne vérifie chaque jour c'est un
jeu de hasard
on ne peut pas savoir ce que nous
réserve un gisement avant d'avoir creusé
et de l'avoir ouvert en alsace
xavier dire que est confiant dans
l'avenir c'est très intéressant de
mettre au point une technologie qui doit
déboucher sur un système durable
[Musique]
son chef paulo à l'expérience en plus
mais pas moins de passion quand on
arrive à avoir le nom sur le compteur
[Musique]
l'islande possède des atouts
incomparables pour l'exploitation de la
géothermie is lang veut dire le pays de
la glace pourtant un peu partout le sol
fume crachote bouillonne nous sommes au
milieu de la zone volcanique occidentale
d'islande où les phénomènes de surface
comme ces fissures érige de chaque côté
il ya une zone plus ancienne qui se
trouvait avant au milieu de la zone de
faille mais qui a dérivé depuis vers
l'est et vers l'ouest
en effet sous d'atlantique la plaque
continentale européenne et la plaque
américaine ces cartes l'une de l'autre
cette séparation a fait apparaître une
longue chaîne de volcans sous-marins
l'islande se trouve à cheval sur cette
faille
[Musique]
la fracture sous marine se traduite en
surface par une énorme cicatrice
à l'est c'est la plaque européenne à
l'ouest la plaque américaine
[Musique]
c'est au milieu de cet échange crurent
qui est implantée la centrale autrefois
station ski elle irradie abrite
aujourd'hui une activité bien plus
productives
[Musique]
les skieurs furent délogés sitôt ce
gisement découvert par les géologues
[Musique]
quand il ne surveille pas la centrale
gretar ivarsson passe son temps à
chercher de nouvelles sources de vapeur
sur les terres alentour in blood
abondamment 80 centimètres par an c'est
pluie s'infiltre dans le sol et vont
rejoindre la chaleur des roches
profondes chaleur et au les deux
ingrédients composant la vapeur
inlassablement le géologue et ses
assistants engrange des données et
étudie des cartes de l'activité
volcanique souterraines pour déterminer
l'emplacement des gisements de vapeur
exploitables
il y a dix ans on a eu un énorme séisme
qui a duré quatre ans et toute cette
zone est monté de 20 à 30 cm c'était dû
à une intrusion magmatique à 7 km de
profondeur
aussi étudié les fumerolles en surface
nous indique si ce magma remonte vers la
surface
non on prend la température des sources
et des bassins
on mesure leur acidité on prélève aussi
des échantillons de gaz dans les sources
et les fumerolles la composition des gaz
et la concentration de certains éléments
nous renseigne directement sur la
température des gisements qui sont sous
nos pieds surface dressons la carte des
gisements et nous savons où il faudrait
creuser si la zone devaient être
exploité plus tard
[Musique]
dans les régions volcaniques qui
bénéficie de la présence simultanée de
chaleur et d'eau on doit forer entre
deux et trois mille mètres de profondeur
on y trouve de la vapeur à près de 300
degrés cette vapeur est acheminée du
puits à la centrale par d'énormes tuyaux
là elle est nettoyée de ses impuretés
avant d'atteindre sa destination finale
le coeur du dispositif la turbine
entraînée par la pression de la vapeur
la turbine transmet son énergie
mécanique un générateur électrique
le principe n'a pas évolué depuis sa
conception il y ait plus d'un siècle une
amélioration toutefois un rideau froid
dans un immense radiateur en sortie de
turbines en créant une dépression ce
raid au froid aspire la vapeur et
accroît son rendement
c'est le condenseur
[Musique]
le condenseur et relis sous terre à une
tour de refroidissement
l'eau qui a chauffé au contact de la
vapeur et pomper jusqu'au sommet de la
tour ou des ventilateurs géants la
disperse
lorsqu elle retombe le simple contact
avec l'air la refroidit suffisamment
qu'elle puisse retourner jouer son rôle
dans le condenseur en islande
même quand l'hiver est là avec ses vents
incessants rien n'arrête le travail
l'extension de l'usiné se poursuit
à l'intérieur on coupe on soude on
assemble des dizaines de milliers
d'éléments une sorte de meccano géant
dont chaque pièce doit être ajusté avec
une précision millimétrique 10
millimètres de trop
non il faut rectifier ça soude une pièce
ici pour que ça ne déborde pas trop 5 mm
maximum et pas de bêtises sinon tu auras
mon pied aux fesses chargés d'ériger
deux nouvelles tours de refroidissement
marcus et son équipe travaillent par
n'importe quel temps ils ont tout aussi
ce délai de six mois à tenir pour que
les nouveaux générateurs sont
opérationnels marcus supervise des
dizaines d'ouvriers dont très peu
d'islandais l'islande est un des pays
les plus développés au monde est aussi
l'un des moins peuplés trois cent mille
habitants seulement
d'où une pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
chronique sur ce chantier nombre
d'ouvriers viennent de pologne et
connaissent pas le domaine de la
géothermie important sur un chantier
comme ça c'est l'expérience
c'est la première fois que ces gars
travaillent avec et il faut tout leur
expliquer de hazel
est ce que c'est qu'un clic et une clé à
molette c'est comment on s'en sert en a
qui utilise ça comme un marteau ou un
pied-de-biche
il faudra qu'ils apprennent vite en
dépassant la barrière de la langue
aucun d'eux ne parle islandais et
certains ne comprennent même pas
l'anglais comprennent l'anglais de base
mais parfois on a vraiment du mal à leur
expliquer certaines choses
alors on va chercher quelqu'un qui parle
anglais il traduit toujours un problème
de langue qui va nous arrêter
c'est comme la météo si on prend la tête
à cause du temps il rêve on est
malheureux en islande
[Musique]
suivant la direction du vent d'énormes
panaches de vapeur enveloppe parfois le
chantier au travail marcus au sommet des
tours
il est impossible d'échapper à la vapeur
voilà donc quelles conditions
travaillent
c'est à peine si je vois mon collègue
d'à côté alors pour communiquer
travailler ensemble ce gaz
c'est super pénible
un de ces au féminisme dont marcus a le
secret en réalité ce gaz est mortelle si
cette vapeur pompé dans les profondeurs
de la terre qui fait vivre la centrale
elle circule dans ses tuyaux comme du
sang dans les veines
le géologue gretar ivarsson a aussi pour
rôle de surveiller la vapeur et ses
composants parfois néfastes
le sodium qui ronge le métal est peu
endommagé les turbines n'est pas le pire
[Musique]
gretar s'éloigne du robinet quand il
sent le danger la vapeur tapis sous la
croûte terrestre porteuse de certaines
substances nocives qu'il est impossible
d'éliminer ces de l'eau géothermale qui
contient des gaz incombant sable tels
que l'hydrogène sulfuré un gaz toxique
là quand je sens qu'il y en a une forte
concentration
oui je recule un peu si la concentration
dépasse 300 à 400 parties par million on
perd connaissance et aux moeurs c'est
donc un gaz très dangereux mais quand on
sait ce qu'il faut éviter il n'y a pas
de prendre la main
on reconnaît la présence d'hydrogène
sulfuré dans l'air à son odeur d'oeuf
pourri mais pour en mesurer la
concentration le doha ne suffit pas
quand marcus et son équipe se trouve
sous le vent comme aujourd'hui est dans
l'incapacité de se soustraire à ces
émanations de vapeurs
ils doivent impérativement se munir d'un
instrument de mesure
[Musique]
on
un détecteur dash deux aces qui indique
la quantité de gaz dans l'air du souffre
en fait celui ci est plus précis et il
émet une sonnerie des bips
si on attend le niveau 18
il faut partir parce que les gens
perdent connaissance au dessus d'un
certain seuil qu'on ne le sens plus très
bien quand on passe dans le secteur en
voiture on sent une légère odeur ça
c'est niveau 2 ou 3 ici on peut
travailler pendant huit heures à un
niveau 15 au dessus de 15
il faut déguerpir
ce matin le seuil critique est atteint
mais tout le monde est là tu n'as pas
d'oxygène dans ce gaz ils se déplacent
par floch et si une poche vous entourent
une seule respiration et vous perdez
connaissance et s'il n'y a personne pour
vous sortir de là c'est la mort assurée
c'est pour ça qu'on travaille par deux
il faut toujours quelqu'un pour vous
épauler et si on meurt tous les deux et
bien équipés en route pour le paradis
en attendant la féliciter paradisiaque
il faut supporter parfois cette
atmosphère infernale et l'invisible
danger qui s'y cachent
[Musique]
sur le chantier la construction des
tours de refroidissement supplémentaire
est déjà bien avancé seule la tour
numéro 4 attend encore ses cheminées et
ses ventilateurs pour installer ces
gaines de ventilation monumental il faut
une grue spéciale une grue géante qui a
été appelé à une mission urgente
ailleurs sur le chantier et n'est donc
pas disponible pour le moment c'est
vraiment la poisse en voudra pas la
récupérer aujourd'hui il faudra attendre
demain on commencera dès que la grue
arrive si elle arrive à 5 heures on
montera au moins une cheminée ça
m'étonnerait installer la grue a déployé
la fixer ce contretemps pourrait saper
le moral des troupes
mais la grue et bientôt la livre est
plutôt prévu l'engin déplie son bras de
géant mais regarde là avec ses quatre
pattes posait sur des morceaux de bois
nous on n'a pas trop confiance
le monstre est en place l'une des plus
grandes grues du pays
elle peut soulever 80 tonnes et des pois
un bras télescopique de 40 m un travail
de précision
pourtant effectué à l'aveuglé le grutier
est guidée uniquement à la voix qu'on a
intérêt à bien communiquer avec le
grutier s'ils descendent trop vite ce
truc pourra casser par exemple il doit
être parfaitement niveau et vous voyez
c'est encore là il ya un demi centimètre
de jeu même pas quelques millimètres
c'est très précis si le grutier à
quelques millimètres de marche pour
poser la cheminée l'équipe
elle devra l'ajuster au dixième de
millimètre près à peine l'épaisseur d'un
ongle pendant tout ce temps bien sûr la
grue reste prête au cas où il faudrait
soulevé la cheminée et ce temps un coup
la location coûte entre 500 et 1000
euros de l'heure mais on ne pense pas ça
ce qui compte c'est de faire le boulot
correctement
pour l'instant on essaie de l'ajuster le
mieux possible
après on utilisera des outils spéciaux
pour affiner il est toujours tentant
d'essayer d'abord la méthode
traditionnelle
[Musique]
mais dans le cas présent seuls les
outils adéquats permettent d'obtenir la
précision voulu à la fin de la journée
les quatre cheminées sont posées on peut
enfin rendre cette grue hors de prix
demain il est prévu de hisser les
ventilateurs
ce sont des dispositifs fragile dont les
pales se cassent facilement
marcus va avoir besoin de quelque chose
de très rare en islande une journée sans
vent
[Musique]
l'islande recèlent les gisements
géothermique les plus productifs au
monde
néanmoins deux gisements situés côte à
côte peuvent produire des quantités de
vapeur très variable comment décider
lequel exploiter c'est la tâche malaisée
qui revient aux scientifiques comme créé
tard
c'est vraiment un coup de chance il est
très difficile d'évaluer un puits avant
de le forez ou avant de l'ouvrir pour la
première fois il nous faut beaucoup de
vapeur
parfois on trouve une vapeur
d'excellente qualité mais en quantité
insuffisante
il nous faut plus de deux kilos de
vapeur par seconde pour produire 1
mégawatt d'électricité
ces puits donne 17 à 18 kg de vapeur
seconde ce qui permet de produire 8 à 9
mégawatts
ils sont très productifs nous en sommes
très contents
grâce à l'électricité géothermique
l'islande est devenu l'un des pays
d'europe dont le revenu par habitant est
le plus élevé
ce don de la terre les gisements de
vapeur semble inépuisable aussi gretar
est il conscient
les nouveaux générateurs pourront
produire à plein régime
on trouvera suffisamment de vapeur on en
a même plus qu'il n'en faut pour
l'instant
[Musique]
à cheval sur sa chaîne de volcans
l'islande réunis à coup sûr les
meilleures conditions pour exploiter la
chaleur des masses rocheuses l'énergie
géothermique est présente dans le monde
entier
mais son exploitation est parfois plus
complexes ainsi à la frontière franco
allemande
il n'y a pas de volcan mais en fabrique
de la vapeur en injectant de l'eau dans
des roches chaudes et sèches situés à
très grande profondeur
c'est tout se réchauffe et se transforme
en vapeur avant d'être pompé en surface
une centrale géothermique s'est
implantée dans le village de soultz les
forêts un projet pilote lancé par un
consortium européen il ya déjà 20 ans
comme tous les pionniers les techniciens
de soultz achoppent sur des
impondérables
le dernier en date une panne de pompe
paulo supervise l'opération avec son
bras droit
xavier peter et un mécanicien islandais
il est ici à titre de conseiller
technique son aide est d'autant plus
précieuse que la pompe incriminés et de
fabrication islandaise
il s'agit d'une pompe d'excellente
qualité mais visiblement les conditions
dans lesquelles on lutte les ici en
alsace ne lui conviennent pas
en islande les géologues dressent des
cartes de l'activité souterraine et
décide ensuite ou et proposeront des
appareils de forage et en perse le sol
24 heures sur 24
au delà des 2000 mètres les feux rouges
tombent sur de la vapeur à 300°
acheminés vers la centrale elle est
transformée en électricité au sortir de
la turbine des résidus de vapeur sont
relâchées dans l'atmosphère
tôt ou tard les précipitations en
pénétrant dans le sous-sol
renouvelleront les réserves et si un
gisement vient à s'épuiser
il suffira de creuser un peu plus loin
en alsace c'est plus compliqué pour
atteindre des roches à 300 degrés on
creuse jusqu'à 5000 m et comme la roche
sèche il faut creuser un puits pour
injecter de l'eau qui se transformera en
vapeur et deux autres pour pomper cette
vapeur en fin de processus
on réinjecte l'eau dans ce circuit fermé
à soultz on utilise évidemment l'eau du
cru or c'est une des plus sales dino
monde sous veut d'ailleurs dire celle en
alsacien le consortium avait deux bonnes
raisons de choisir cet endroit pour
implanter l'usine-pilote sa situation
centrale en europe et la présence de
roches chaudes dans le sous-sol la
salinité de l'eau ne devait être qu'un
inconvénient mineur
elle se révèle un peu plus fâcheuses
à cause de la salinité élevée de l'eau
et le nombre de particules qui sont dans
lyon on a abîmé la mission la pompe
elle vient d'islande et en islande l'eau
est moins minéralisée que la nôtre est
maintenant le cherchant un nouveau metal
pour refaire la pompe
on doit donc trouver un nouveau matériau
qui peut supporter ce genre d'eau ont ce
n'est pas si facile à trouver
en attendant de trouver une nouvelle
pompe qui résistera à la corrosion
les techniciens font une réparation de
fortune et remettre celle ci en place
c'est juste en attendant nous avons des
tests à faire et nous savons que cette
pompe avec l'ancien métal ne durera pas
longtemps mais assez pour faire les
tests en cours
après on arrivera tout et on changera la
pompe elle même
normalement ils posent 15 à 20 segment
de tubes en une journée
aujourd'hui pressés d'achever leur
réparation ils ont opposé plus de 25
on a été aussi vite que possible oui on
a fait du bon boulot aujourd'hui
peter insiste pour qu'il s'en pose un
dernier ait fini par convaincre l'équipe
[Musique]
remontez la pompe leur demandera encore
beaucoup de temps ce qui n'empêche pas
que xavier de voir les choses du bon
côté
[Applaudissements]
dans ma tête ça va bien si ça tient
comme ça jusqu'à vendredi
si on y arrive c'est bon ça paraît très
bien
il leur faudra bien plusieurs jours de
travail avant de pouvoir tester leur
réparation sous le morne ciel d'islande
l'équipe de markus commence à poser les
ventilateurs géants des tours de
refroidissement
ils doivent les fixes et bien solidement
car leurs pâles tourneront à plus de 100
kilomètres heure
[Musique]
sert le c'est facile avec ce petit outil
il a fallu une grue géante pour soulever
les ventilateurs il faut à présent des
outils surdimensionné pour serrer
correctement les boulons c'est mon outil
préféré c'est vraiment dur normalement
pour serrer un boulon il faut une force
de 10 newtons mètres
il en faut 1200 c'est un laisser aller
c'est assez lourd
j'ai peur de lâcher la clé
marcus doit serré jusqu au clic indique
que le serrage dont l'ue est atteint
mille cent soixante mille 180
on a atteint le serrage maximale pour ce
beau mais il va falloir en faire autant
sur plusieurs dizaines de boulons ford
islande fait un ventilateur il en reste
3 il n'y aura pas l'embellie espérée au
contraire phénomène rare une tempête
tropicale est venu se perdre au fin fond
de l'atlantique nord les soudeurs eux
sont à l'abri par nécessité les autres
doivent travailler dehors envers et
contre tout comme marcus
à l'intérieur des cheminées ils sont
protégés du vent mais pas de ces averses
persistantes la pluie complique
énormément les choses pour les hommes
bien sûr mais aussi pour le matériel
fourni des outils pas étanche pour venir
travailler dans la région la pelouse
humide du pays
on est obligé de les protéger avec du
plastique et on n'arrive pas à lire au
travers et glissant je suis trompé parce
que je suis toujours comme ça que l'eau
coule dans mes manches c'est super de
travailler sous la pluie c'est ce qu'on
dit mais bon je suis payé pour ça
cette étudiante marine embauchés pour
l'été vient aider marcus a vérifié
l'inclinaison des pales 7° ne s'est pas
refait il faut qu'on soit 7,8 ou 7,9 ou
huit
rien d'autre ce n'est pas simple de
bouger sa de seulement 0,1 degré c'est
dingue
les problèmes les plus inattendus
peuvent interrompre le travail parfois
des problèmes de taille
on essaie de trouver une caisse parce
qu'elle est trop petit pour voir au
dessus des parle toujours des gags comme
ça dégager de ce petit inconvénient
marine peut enfin lire les chiffres sur
le niveau il y à un nouveau problème
pardon
[Musique]
maintenant que la pris de la hauteur
elle aurait besoin d'un mégaphone le
genre d'appareil difficile à trouver sur
un chantier marine devra élever le ton
08 7,9
[Musique]
roulis et le chef de marcus venus
d'allemagne
il travaille depuis 15 ans maintenant en
islande c'est un expert en construction
de tours de refroidissement mais asseoir
sa réputation lui a demandé certains
sacrifices
je ne vois ma famille que trois mois par
an je suis marié à mon boulot ma femme
passe après je suis désolé de le dire
mais c'est la vérité
cet été son fils steven l'a rejoint sur
le chantier il veut passer son permis de
conduire s'acheter une voiture
je lui ai dit viens travailler ici tu
gagneras de l'argent et on sera ensemble
tout le temps où lee ne verse pas pour
autant dans les favoris tisme c'était
parfois temps c'est aussi durement que
les autres
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'humeur du chef est à
l'image du temps exécrable et les
prévisions annoncent encore une
dégradation
là c'est différent il pleut et il ya un
vent terrible et c'est comme une tempête
avec des rafales de vent en hiver c'est
plus stable
je sais pas c'est autre chose on n'a pas
l'habitude de st
pendant le passage de la tempête
tropicale les trois autres ventilateurs
vont sagement attendre au sol trop
fragile pour être secoué par un tel vent
c'était quelque chose de plus gros on
pourrait le monter ceux là sont trop
fragile et on ne veut pas prendre le
moindre risque
alors chacun s'occupe mais on perd du
temps avec les ventilateurs
j'espère qu'on sera quand même dans les
temps il faudrait pour cela que la
tempête veuille bien regagner sans délai
ces latitudes tropicales
à soultz en alsace c'est l'heure de
vérité il a fallu plus de temps que
prévu pour bricoler la pompe défectueuse
et la remettre en place
mais fonctionnera-t-elle c'est le tendon
d'achille du système toute l'équipe en
est consciente
on est un peu stressé parce que nous
devons être sûrs que chaque étape se
déroule bien et augmenter et diminuer
progressivement la circulation pour être
sûr que la pompe fonctionne bien
la ponte semble décidé à tous la
pression monte
la tension monte également chez les
ingénieurs contrôlant l'alimentation des
turbines
tout va bien jusqu'à ce que xavier des
saluts d'anomalies moi j'ai la flotte
qui coule j'en ai même plus qu'avant
les indicateurs de pression sont en
rouge
là bas non sur dépasse les 40% tut tut
l'arrêtent
[Musique]
il n'y a pas d'autre solution que
d'interrompre les serres les ingénieurs
cogite cherchent la faille
ils s'apercevront bientôt 15 juin de la
pompe a lâché la consternation est
générale
la température dans les bureaux tout mon
travail parce qu'un jouet cassé et nous
devons le remplacer pour changer ce
joint ne faut aucune pression dans le
puits et pour diminuer la pression on
injecte de l'eau salée ça prend du temps
et de l'argent
ce n'est pas si simple de faire de la
géothermie
l'adjonction de sel augmente la densité
de l'eau et fait baisser son niveau
on appelle cela tuer le puits par un
singulier paradoxe le sel qui s'est
avéré il y à peu leurs ennemis se
transforme en alliés cette panne de
pompe leur a déjà fait perdre beaucoup
de temps et il faut attendre encore que
le sel et fait son office
[Musique]
une semaine plus tard les voilà prêts à
faire un nouvel essai la pression va
jusqu'à l'échangeur donc le film peint
et en os il ya la pète en boîte et
retourne tout et tout a été vérifié
plusieurs fois chacun est à son poste
paulo aux manettes 16e aux commandes
ouais ouais c'est ça
ouais j'ai ouvert les capteurs de
pression du filtre 1 est ce que tu vois
quelque chose dessus j'ai pas encore
quelques réglages
il faut que ça marche et enfants la
pression monte de la vapeur circulent
dans la pompe
[Musique]
maintenant avec la circulation que nous
avons dans cette pompe on va produire de
l'électricité
nous sommes fiers ce qu'on fait on est
un peu stressé parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de risques de pression sur l'équipe mais
on est fiers ce qu'on fait maintenant
la méthode fonctionne
reste à l'appliquer à grande échelle on
l'a déjà fait sur une très courte
période
vous nous dites qu'on envisage c'est de
le faire sur une longue très longue
période c'est à dire pour dire à
l'habitant de l'énergie électrique via
la géothermie des roches profondes
utiliser la géothermie des roches
profondes pour la production combinée
d'électricité et de chaleur
cela se fait déjà en allemagne à
quelques kilomètres de soultz
[Musique]
la centrale de lindau alimentent environ
6000 foyers en électricité et 300 en
chauffage
partenaire de la société exploitant
cette centrale vior baumgartner fait
également partie du consortium de soultz
il a monté sa propre entreprise de
forage en allemagne le gouvernement
allemand encourage la géothermie par des
prêts à taux préférentiels
c'est ainsi que la centrale de lindau a
vu le jour et aussi grâce à l'ardente
conviction de york baumgartner la
géothermie relève pour moi de
l'ingéniérie minière on a des
environnements différents
une tectonique différentes une chimie
différentes
il suffit de tout adapté ses conditions
en plus on a des températures
inférieures à celles des régions
volcaniques que la plupart des gens
associés à la géothermie un ici il n'ya
pas de volcan mais on a quand même de
l'énergie géothermique en grande
quantité
visiblement prête à les exploiter
l'allemagne a beaucoup d'autres projets
en cours
[Musique]
en islande la tempête tropicale a passé
son chemin
comme chaque matin à 7h30 marcus arrive
de reykjavik
et comme chaque matin ils sacrifient à
un rituel imposé jouer avec bruno c'est
pas obligatoire mais un jour je lui ai
fabriqué un gilet et c'est devenu la
règle et avancent à la sécurité
n'auraient même pas imaginer un gilet
pour chiens
aupic il a trois mois il vit sur les
chantiers tout le monde le connaît et
c'est un bon chien de garde
quand on travaille sur les tours il sait
que c'est notre domaine ainsi des
ouvriers d'autres sociétés arrivent avec
d'autres uniformes ils aboient
c'est vraiment un bon chien les collines
derrière moi là c'est chez lui je
connais peu de chiens qui est une aussi
belle vie et autant de liberté heureux
comme pas deux et gâtés croyez-moi quand
marcus a commencé ce chantier ont
pulvérisé de l'eau bouillante dans les
fondations de la tour 4 pour l'empêcher
de geler la tour 3 n'était encore qu'un
squelette les ouvriers des néophytes
au bout du compte les néophytes sont
devenus de vrais professionnels et sont
même en avance sur le calendrier pour
construire une tour selon contraint ces
cinq à six mois la première tour
on a mis cinq mois maintenant il nous
faut plus de trois mois
il ne dit pas aux clients
en plein vent sous la pluie
ces funambules ont accompli dans les
temps un travail difficile et souvent
dangereux beaucoup de chance pas
d'accident grave
deux ou trois doigts cassés rien de bien
méchant une chance et on a quand même
construit cette tour ici les tours sont
enfin terminés prête à être raccordé à
louzine c'est maintenant à l'intérieur
du bâtiment principal que l'on met la
dernière main aux installations et aux
ultimes réglages
[Musique]
alors qu'on procède aux essais finaux
avant de lancer les turbines des
ingénieurs allemands détecte un problème
dans le condenseur l'une des pompes
amenant l'eau dans les tours de
refroidissement ne fonctionne pas ce qui
veut dire qu'il est impossible de mettre
la centrale en route on démarre un
circuit de refroidissement avec deux
pompes parallèle et une seule dépense
devrait tourner et bien de faire un
essai de ce côté cette pompe la tourne
bien et génère une pression d'environ
1,5 bas ce qui est normal cette pompe ci
génèrent une pression de zéro ce qui
veut dire que l'eau ne coule pas alors
que les pompes sont parfaitement
parallèles
il doit y avoir un problème côté
aspirations
sans cette pompe le condenseur ne peut
fonctionner une anicroche qui bloquent
l'usiné toute entière quand la pompe
numéro un était en marche on avait un
maximum de pression tous les ingénieurs
de la centrale unissent leurs
compétences pour tenter de résoudre la
difficulté on va mettre en route la
pompe numéro un
ouvrir la soupape démarrer et vérifiez
la pression
après on fera pareil de ce côté s'il n'y
a pas de pression
il faudra ouvrir
[Musique]
l'ayant dessinée aucune anomalie
il décide d'ouvrir la tubulure pour
examiner la valve c'est peut-être elle
la fautive
[Musique]
mais laval fonctionnent normalement elle
est peut-être bloqués
on a vu qu'elle fonctionnait normalement
lors
nous leur mais à défaut d'une solution
ils remettent la valve en place et font
un nouvel essieu
ok je sors mon cas
[Musique]
regarde on a l'impression maintenant
cette foutue soupapes avait juste besoin
d'un coup de pouce il y à des fantômes
dans le coin c'est peut-être ça enfin
maintenant on a de la pression tout va
bien quelque chose a dû forcer ce clapet
à se fermer
et quand on l'a démontée pour le sortir
il s'est débloqué maintenant il marchait
bien
non au delà on retrouve marcus perché
comme d'habitude dans les hautes sphères
mais pas dans une tour cette fois je
suis en vacances
non mais on a fini là bas et comme on
n'a pas besoin de moi je me suis trouvé
dans notre boulot quand ils m'ont
demandé où je voulais aller il faisait
un temps pourri alors j'ai choisi de
travailler à l'intérieur
et depuis il fait super beau mais c'est
pas grave je vais peindre et si pendant
une semaine c'est pas mal de faire un
peu autre chose ça fait deux ans et demi
que je travaille sur les tours je suis
content de faire un job différents je
pense que dans 1 ans jusqu'après
retourner construire des tours d'ici là
je me repose je pourrais partir en
vacances congés sans solde évidemment
d'y revenir
je suis pas décidé encore c'est ça qui
est sympa vient dé planifier
tant que j'ai du boulot et tout je suis
maintenant je suis l'homme à tout faire
j'ai pas réfléchir
aucun compte à rendre c'est pas mal
les nouveaux générateurs ont été mises
en route dans les délais prévus
[Musique]
en moins d'un an la centrale a doublé
son rendement en islande 90% de la
population dispose déjà du chauffage
géothermique et les villes sont
alimentés en eau chaude directement par
les centrales
[Musique]
gretar everson continue à explorer le
terrain en quête de nouveaux gisements
de vapeur à exploiter là ils surveillent
un nouveau fruit qui sera bientôt
raccordé aux turbines en mesurant la
température à tous les niveaux du puits
on peut savoir si elle est constante ou
si au contraire elle a tendance à
augmenter ou à diminuer à mesure que
l'on descend des informations
essentielles sur l'ensemble du gisement
si on reprend ces mesures pendant
quelques semaines ou un mois on sera à
quel rythme la température augmente
actuellement on n'a que 240 à 250 degrés
est-ce qu'elle va atteindre 270 280 300
degrés
on verra la centrale de elisha ai dit
viens de passer de 90 à 180 mégawatts
mais on espère toujours mieux
on espère atteindre 300 mégawatts les
estimations les plus optimistes parlent
de 400 mais je trouve ça optimiste
depuis que vous entendez derrière moi
produit 19 mégawatts d'électricité et
celui qui est plus à l'est
produit 25 à 26 mégawatts
c'est le meilleur rendement au monde
paraît-il
nous sommes donc très satisfaits de ces
gisements
il y en a qui sont moins bons mais il
faut forer aussi de mauvais puits afin
de savoir quelle est la superficie dont
nous disposons où sont les limites de
notre zone
[Musique]
cependant avec la récente extension le
réseau de tuyaux de et les chats et 10
est déjà trop dense pour être étendue
davantage il va falloir construire une
deuxième centrale à côté
d'années en années l'énergie
géothermique gagne du terrain
le développement des lèche heidi est une
avancée notable vers l'objectif visé par
l'islande être d'ici à 2050
le premier pays à ne plus dépendre ni du
charbon ni du pétrole diversifier notre
approvisionnement énergétique est
maintenant une urgence la géothermie
petit contribuer dans bien des pays
l'islande le prouve et le projet de
soultz ouvre des perspectives
prometteuses
il est désormais parfaitement possible
de faire de la chaleur que nous offre la
terre l'énergie de demain
[Musique]